oui
bruxelles au mois de novembre nous
sommes bien loin de la moiteur des rues
d'istanbul et pourtant la capitale belge
a derrière sa grisaille dr d'anatolie
aujourd'hui cinquante mille turcs vivent
ici
leur histoire est celle d'une lente
intégration d'une affaire de génération
et de famille comme celle d'al il callas
patron d'un snack au coeur du quartier
européen de la ville nous notre point
fort c'est l'epita comme vous voyez là
et on a un petit peu de tout quoi de
restauration c'est un peu les plats
typiques turcs ont percé mussidan
c'est la deuxième génération pour 60 3
963 après 5 en 1968 toute la famille
avec mon père
de trois ans cinq ans travaillent
environ sergent 80 pays ce
phénomène
tout le monde a tellement bien installé
à
ce poste ce film ça solal le perdre à
lille un ouvrier à la retraite qui n'a
jamais fait d'études il n'a pu
transmettre au fiston que le sens du
travail et des affaires
aujourd'hui à lille emploie six
personnes et investit dans l'immobilier
comme pour lui le moteur de
l'intégration des turcs en belgique
c'est la réussite économique on est
content
on essaie de vivre
j'ai pas mal
ça va on n'a pas cela bruxelles n'a donc
pas attendu d'être la capitale de
l'europe pour établir des relations
particulières avec la turquie
l'expérience euro turc halil la fait
tous les jours ils travaillent à deux
pas du parlement européen ici c'est le
grand bâtiment où ce que les 27
ministres quand il vient de faire le
sommet européen donc c'est ici c'est
dans ce bâtiment mais ici c'est le
bâtiment berlemont c'est le grand
bâtiment le plus grand donc à 10000 en
fonctionnaires qui travaillent la limite
et ça c'est le rond point schuman donc
c'est le centre de l'europe on va dire
le coeur de leur office difficile de
trouver turcs eux plus européen que à
lille depuis dix ans la turquie frappe à
la porte de l'union européenne les
négociations traînent la france comme
l'allemagne persiste à s'y opposer une
question qui touche à lille au coeur si
lui a bien su prospérer dans la vieille
europe pourquoi pas la turquie
moi je pense que si on était un pays qui
n'était pas musulman admettons qu'ils
étaient catholiques moi je pense qu'on
était déjà depuis longtemps
en leur poids c'est triste à dire mais
moi oui eux ils disent que c'est pas
vrai c'est vexant oui c'est très vexant
il ya douze pays qui est rentré sur cinq
ans et ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'il nous
manque quand on regarde ces pays-là la
turquie qu'est ce que les manques on est
fort comme chaque semaine à lille est en
route pour saluer son grand père l'un
des premiers turcs à avoir posé ses
valises ici dans le quartier de
schaerbeek c'est le quartier turc sur la
chaussée date à schaerbeek donc ici
c'est tous les pizzerias turcs les
restaurants turc le café turc on va dire
le petit ami jacques lemire d'accès une
petite ville
pas loin d'ankara c'est la majorité des
gens qui vivra bruxelles donc tu vas
rencontrer dit personne ici à sterrebeek
et vont dire la wii qui vont dire qu'ils
sont des miracles
schaerbeek c'est le quartier natal dalil
ici les turcs venus des mires d'agde ont
un peu reconstitué leur village un coin
rassurant dans lequel il a grandi mais
aujourd'hui la déménager les gens y
vivent ici et ils vont au café
ils sortent dans les mamies y voit les
amis et le soir ils rentrent donc ils
sont fermés quoi dans un circuit fermé
ils vont nulle part serra ils vont juste
ou en turquie en vacances quoi y'a
beaucoup de turquie vit comme ça
bonjour za ça c'est le quartier où j'ai
vécu
par an chez saida et sa célèbre pour ses
enfants à lille a choisi une école et un
quartier plus huppés n'est pas question
de renier ses racines on revient souvent
à schaerbeek rendre visite au patriarche
mon grand-père donc c'est monsieur et
vous voyez
il est né en 1929 c'est le musée qui est
un des premiers qui est venu en belgique
mais m le doyen est venue de turquie à
pied ici il était ouvrier dans une usine
de café
dans les années 64 65 ans est arrivé
quand il habitait il habitait à quatre à
cinq personnes et comment son chauffeur
s'en
mêler les cartes en question
moi je suis venu
je suis content donc demandé mes enfants
il avait beaucoup de petites filles
c'est tout
il espère qu'ils firent windows utilise
qui deviennent quelque chose d'eux
qu'ils deviennent les gens importants
voilà
le défi qui attend la dernière
génération des turcs de bruxelles c'est
la réussite à l'école ici à l'université
libre alta neffati sont en troisième
année de droit ils sont tous deux natifs
du quartier turc de schaerbeek et ont
bien l'intention de briser le vase clos
dans lequel ils ont grandi
lorsqu'une personne vient de turquie à
schaerbeek généralement par le biais de
mariage elle après trois ans pas mais il
n'a pas besoin d'apprendre un mot aux
français
parce que il ya des dentistes turc des
avocats turc
il ya même une éco turc donc voila quoi
par exemple mon père est ici depuis 30
ans met à parler chiffres national
français il se débrouille pour tout
oublier la débrouille viser les diplômés
casser les clichés nous deux futurs
avocats n'ont pas de problème d'identité
turcot belge ou belgo turc ils savent
très bien sur quel pied danser moi je ne
vois surtout
comme un pont entre deux communautés
d'une part il ya une communauté qui
était menée sur soi-même et d'une part
nous la 3e génération on veut notre
place dans cette société pas en tant que
communautés et citoyens d'une communauté
turque n'entend qu'eux un citoyen belge
des citoyens belges fin connaisseur de
la société turque à la question la
turquie intégrera tel un jour l'union
européenne de deux futurs avocats
plaident la différence je pense que la
turquie ne rentrera jamais dans l'union
européenne mais pourquoi tour tandis que
voilà la turquie va entrer dans la danse
je pense que font juste voir la question
peut-être sur un sofa un autre en guest
que l a vraiment envie et à quel prix je
veux dire s'il est si la turquie doit de
rentrer dans l'union européenne ce
serait quand même un prix considérable
la turquie et l'europe un concept autour
duquel gloseront certainement encore des
générations de politologues au fond
qu'importe alta neffati sondés euro turc
bien dans leurs baskets
retour à schaerbeek mais m le patriarche
et à lille son petit fils sont un
rendez-vous de la plus haute importance
ce soir à l'amicale des supporters du
club de foot de trabzon on diffuse un
classique du championnat turc
trabzonspor galatasaray
[Musique]
un bon prétexte pour palabrer boire un
thé jouer aux dominos à la turque
j'ai vraiment aimé turquois vraiment
dans la halle avec la communauté turque
à bruxelles c'est plus ou moins connaît
même ambiance mans par tout ce qui
s'appelle café comme ça et tu vas le
voir maintenant ils sont tous remplis
conseillère de match complètement nous
avons une équipe hors ligue des
champions souvent d'aller les équipes
qu'on fait là bâti qui dresseraient mais
cette année ils sont éliminés
mais sinon il joue la coupe d'europe les
gabardans software